hi my name is Laura Wexler and I'm a
professor in American Studies and women
gender and sexuality studies
and I'm a historian of photography and
I'm deeply involved in the process of
the creation of digital humanities
projects and curricula here at Yale and
one thing that can panko didn't mention
in the morning that I also want to tell
you about is that on the year after next
so that's 2014-2015 I will lead a
year-long mellon Foundation sponsored
interdisciplinary digital humanities
course for graduate students which is
the first of its kind in the university
so I'm really really interested in these
questions of their creation of curricula
and bottom-up innovation and flexibility
and all these things and also the
support that we've been hearing about so
far now briefly I just want to say a
minute about how did I get here someone
like me and then i'm going to introduce
peter one of the things that yale does
very well is to teach our students how
to tell a story about their academic
lives the faculty sometimes learns to do
this as well but we also tend to stick
with the professional stories that we've
made and once they're polished they
don't get amended all that much in my
own case the story that i learned to
tell involves the fact that i began to
imagine a career in humanities in a
university as an undergraduate student
at MIT where i studied both photography
and the humanities upon graduating from
Columbia with a PhD in English and
comparative literature I had two job
offers one was from the American Studies
faculty at Amherst College a great
American Studies program and one was to
go back and join the humanities faculty
at MIT and I to amend Robert Frost chose
the path more traveled and I went to
Amherst College and then eventually to
Yale teaching American Studies but in
fact all the time that other path the
lessons I learned at MIT about problem
solve problem based scholarship team
based research the capacity of
engineering to illuminate the visual
world these lessons and the passion for
the technological underpinnings of
thought have always informed
my humanities scholarship and in fact if
you go back I was originally a 17th
century scholar and if you go back in
European history as well the science is
not separate from the humanities
recently through my work in helping to
develop the digital humanities at Yale
I've been able to bring these two
long-standing passions together and this
convergence i think is on offer here for
everyone the paths not taken also
actually do reappear and right now are
reappearing now is an exceptionally
promising time for those of us in the
humanities at yale to re-examine the
story arc that we have been telling
about our own formations as humanists
and to see where some of those
excitement's of the past merge with the
new opportunities that are opening up
for all of us I want to share one of my
own recent insights with you we in the
humanities often think of working with
computers as working in different
languages which for one reason or
another we failed to learn in college we
think that there is an X programming
language and a y programming language on
a-z programming language and of course
this is true but I have spent the last
several years and small and large groups
listening to engineers and programmers
and others talk about digital humanities
projects and often they are talking
about in in languages that i do not know
and understand however recently
something quite remarkable happened to
me and suddenly I began to understand
what all this talk about these different
languages had to do with topics that are
especially and passionately interesting
to me I think of this as the Helen
Keller moment do you remember when Annie
Sullivan held her one hand under the
water flowing from the pump and signed
the word water into a palm of her other
hand and suddenly this blind and deaf
child made the connection between the
word and the thing she is born into
language and from that point her place
in the world as a reasoning being is
forever changed
spectacularly augmented this I think is
what is going on for us now what we are
studying with the digital humanities is
not only languages digital programs
computer language x y and z it is a new
stage of language itself and the human
world the human place in the world is
forever changed by it this is our Helen
Keller moment so now I'd like to
introduce Peter Leonard Peter Leonard
holds a BA in art history from the
University of Chicago and an MA and a
PhD in Swedish literature from the
University of Washington he is currently
right now responsible for humanities
research computing at the University of
Chicago he is a co-principal
investigator of a google digital
humanities grant that uses topic
modeling as a technique for exposing
hidden structure in the volumes of
google books he was the organizer of the
2012 Chicago colloquium on digital
humanities and computer science he has
taught and published in the field of
Scandinavian literature as well as
digital humanities and he is the
recipient of many awards and recognition
in both arenas he has been a haystack
scholar he has held a Fulbright
scholarship at the up solo Center for
multi ethnic research in Sweden and most
recently a digital a Google digital
humanities research award his interest
in contemporary nordic literature peter
says is specifically about quote new
post ethnic configurations of national
belonging in scandinavian fiction and he
writes i am broadly interested in
digital and quantitative methods in the
humanities including text mining network
analysis image analysis and corpus query
engines this means that he brings
special interest in analysis and
visualization using large bodies of
electronic text in networks and
large-scale text analysis and in issues
and inspiration to be found in libraries
those are the titles of some of his
recent papers but peter is also the
incoming librarian for digital
humanities research at yale university
many of us greatly to our benefit
we'll be working with and learning from
him soon when he came here for his job
talk not only was he inspiring and
visionary as a digital humanities
practitioner he easily made a great big
room full of diverse people very excited
about Scandinavian literature I am very
delighted to ask you to please join me
in welcoming Peter to this conference
and to Yale Thank You Laura for a
wonderful very kind introduction I
promise there's only one slide innocent
our entire PowerPoint with whom louts on
it so it's nothing to fear it seems like
I can still remember when Mark Turan
asked me to give a talk here today seems
like only yesterday and up when he did
so I thought about what are the ways
that I could sort of try to contribute
something to a conversation which so
many senior people from whom we heard
today have already given their insight
and the way I thought I might be able to
at least start a conversation here would
be to talk about digital scholarship
probably conceived and the archive
broadly conceived and I want to use the
word archive as opposed to library
although we are standing inside a
library certainly one of the great ones
in North America if not the world
because I think that although the
library stands at the center of a lot of
collective practice and stands at the
center of a lot of scholarship we want
to think about not only the holdings of
by Nikki and of sterling and other
libraries on campus but also the
holdings of individual faculty members
and graduate students the holdings of of
text mining operations that have been
going on for a long time the holdings of
journals so I want to think about the
archive and a kind of generic sense and
I want to think about the impact of the
digital on the archive and in thinking
about that I thought that there might be
two ways that we could understand the
impact of the digital broadly conceived
on the archive and it seems to me that
it's unquestionable that the digital has
brought an enormous challenge to us at
least in the humanities and the history
fields which is it brings us the
challenge of scale we have organizations
which are central to a lot of our
research such as Google Books hottie
trust JSTOR the internet archive that
are giving us anywhere from a couple
thousand up to 20 million books in the
case of google books right now this is
kind of an unprecedented challenge of
scale for people in the humanities and
in history and an allied fields who were
used to worrying it working at the scale
of intimate texts but there's also
something else that the the digital
brings to the archive and it brings new
approaches and these new approaches can
be thought of as a response to the
challenge of scale so in the language of
computer science in the language of
people who are used to dealing with big
data and thinking about algorithms to
make sense of that data we have sort of
overall umbrella of machine learning we
have phrases like latent semantic
analysis the implicit structure of
unlabeled data and all of these terms
have been sort of reinterpreted and
given humanistic labels by practitioners
within the field in the last couple
years we have Franklin Reddy's term of
distant reading we have Stephen Ramsey's
term of algorithmic criticism Martin
Muller from Northwestern uses the phrase
scalable reading and each of these asked
us to complement not replace but
compliments are close reading the thing
in which most of us are trained with a
kind of macroscopic perspective so a
zoom out as opposed to a zoom in and as
we were talking about this type of
perspective this type of complementary
approach to reading at great distance
and reading a very short distance is
really important for all of these
archives that I've put up ranging from
the 20 million books in google books all
the way down to a phrase that David used
just today the thematic research archive
something which could be relatively
small stored locally perhaps maintained
and built locally and you've got all
these things in between special
collections people doing research
digitization JSTOR's data for research
program all of these archives small and
large I think both suffer from problems
of scale but also have the opportunity
to meet that challenge through through
new techniques and in thinking about my
subtitle microscopes and Mac
scoffs I started thinking about a panel
at the MLA this year in Boston which was
called literature laboratories and the
interesting thing this brought together
people from University braska Lincoln
and Stanford and Harvard Metalab all
those people thinking about the
literature laboratory as a concept and
this notion of the literature laboratory
was once I think somebody told the story
of Gerhard Casper the leader of Stanford
saying when he's first proposed that he
should help fund the literature
laboratory isn't that a contradiction in
terms Gerhard asked and I think one of
the ways that that question was answered
at the MLA panel was at the word lab the
word laboratory is actually doing some
work it's doing some labor in that
phrase in that compound phrase the
literature laboratory that the
laboratory implies a space of
exploration of collaboration of
empiricism for good or for ill for
methodological innovation
experimentation and sometimes for
failure and so in thinking about the
humanistic laboratory I thought well
what what kind of lab equipment would
you want in such a space whether it's
physical or virtual whether it exists in
a library or a computing center or just
in our heads and it strikes to me that
you know the things that we are trained
to do in the humanities and histories
often to make small things large to
spend years analyzing them and reading
them carefully and that's of course what
microscopes do right but macro scopes do
the opposite they make small thing they
make large things small they allow you
to zoom out and that the notion of a
humanistic macroscope actually at least
as far as i can tell comes from kadhi
burner who is a professor informatics at
indiana university and i think that this
notion of a macroscope zooming out on
big data is compatible with martin
Mueller's notion of scalable reading you
can see this is Martin Mueller's blog
you have a kind of telescope up there
right which is really bringing the
distant close but you could imagine
flipping that telescope around and
making things which seem quite close to
you to be far away these microscopes in
these macro scopes have we've known that
these types of tools have been important
for a long time all the way back in 2006
I crane writes this article what do you
do with a million books we now the
problem what do you do with 20 million
books and of course the reality is many
disciplines haven't done a great job of
dealing with this problem of scale even
in the analog world so Franco Moretti
writes this terrifically titled article
in 2000 called the slaughter house of
literature and he says majority of books
disappear forever and majority actually
misses the point if we set today's canon
of 19th century British novels at two
hundred titles which would be very high
they would still only be out 0.5% of all
published novels which is visualized
down at the bottom this this sort of
grade on red to use the language of
Moretti this is present in every
subfield no matter how obscure how
unimportant in my own field this is what
the 19th century print explosion looks
like in Scandinavia captured by google
books at least until the 19 23 copyright
cut off so this is about 160,000 books
in my small field I did the math and if
each volume is of forty thousand words
then that's about six billion for it
it's a lot of words you have to keep in
your mind nobody can keep all that words
in their head in the same time nobody
can read that many words in a lifetime
so you have to redefine what it is to
read and the good news is we're going to
get help with that from disciplines that
perhaps we haven't worked very closely
with in the past disciplines such as
computer science statistics information
retrieval one way of thinking about
making the macroscope concrete is to
take a case study and it's a case study
of modernist poetry which is a field
that's being investigated by a couple
faculty members of Chicago and the
interesting thing about this field is
its of course moderns and the many
modernism's and they occur different
points in the globe and in different
spaces and in different understandings
modernist poetry shares in many
countries this notion of the little
magazine the sort of poetry journal that
collects the stuff and publishes it so
there's this interesting site of
publication in the history of modernist
poetry and also alluded to the question
of globalism and trans Nationals and
these poems are often translated and
appear in different countries and so we
have this interesting concretization of
the exchange of ideas across national
boundaries you can see some of the data
I'm about to present at literary
networks about you chicago de tu
but when we were thinking about this
problem of modernist poetry writ large
we thought about a couple different ways
of trying to solve this problem of
trying to get into this archive we
thought well maybe we'll just look for
keywords within all of modernist poetry
well look for the word love or we'll
look for the word nation or something
like that and you can imagine the
problems with this is that it you have
to know what the corpus is before you
know what the words to look for you
thought maybe we'll use cataloguing
metadata maybe we'll look up all the
poems that are filed under the subject
love or all the all the all the poems
that are tagged niall isn't right well
the problem is they really aren't really
good subject indices to these types of
poems at a granular level and the last
idea we came up with is maybe we should
let the poems organize themselves give
them some agency in the matter and you
know most people when they hear this
idea they think that's that's not going
to work that's crazy talk so what's dig
a little bit deeper into this notion of
self organizing data there are a lot of
different ways of doing this right we
have explicit and we also have implicit
signals we have things we metadata
that's explicit about the date of the
poems and we have also latent signals
within the text itself let's start with
explicit because that's I think a little
easier to think through at first we know
who published what poems in what
journals and if we want access to this
data we need a very comprehensive
bibliography for each country we're
considering and the good news is we have
that we have about as you can see at the
bottom 100,000 discreet publication
events from Japan from the 1920s to the
1940s so now suddenly no we know exactly
who published what and where so
unfortunately buddy wants to scroll
through a hundred thousand rows in a
sequel table so maybe another way to
think about this data is to think about
as a graph of interconnected nodes every
time a poet publishes a poem in a
journal we can draw a line between that
poet and journal so when Carl Sandburg
first publishes the Chicago poem in
poetry magazine we get an edge between
two nodes and what would that look like
if we had that data at a scale of a
hundred thousand publication events in
the case of Japan a sort of looks like
this and what we can do is we can
actually look at that
I've so here are a couple is actually
just a couple years 1929 931 in Japan
you can immediately see that there are
two really important journals she Toshi
Ron and Xin which are here I can further
kind of query this graph and I can say
I'm interested in a particular poet and
I can drill down on him and see the
journals in which Cassano shrimp a
published every time I hover over
different poets and journals I can see
their network they're sort of connection
to each other right so this is an
example of the simple who published what
we're but we can do more interesting
things we can find all the foreigners
through poems whose poems were published
in Japan and we can find out where those
poems were translated in and what
journals they appeared and then we can
ask an algorithm to detect clusters to
find communities of certain types of
foreigners we get published in some
journal and others would get published
in another journal and what this means
is that you have essentially foreign
poets in Japanese journals that Co here
that's every color there is a separate
cluster you could also say that you know
enough about the ground truth of the
literary history in Japan to say that
you know who was a high modernist poet
and who was an anarchist poet and if you
knew who was an anarchist you could tag
that particular poet and then every
single time that he or she published a
poet in a poem in a journal you could
make that edge or that line pink and
would that would be a way of
understanding the position of the
anarchists at certain points in time
what were their publication networks
like you can even think about the
spatialization of publication data
because people have birth places and
they have places where they're
productive and journals are published at
certain places so here you can see we're
moving through the 1920s and we're
looking at these are actually journals
the ones in red are anarchists journals
the ones in blue are high modernist
journals and this is just a live view of
a current satellite photography of
Google Earth but what it's doing is it's
showing you who is publishing what in
different parts of Tokyo right you could
also zoom out and think about the ways
that we understand Japan today as being
different from the ways that Japan
understood itself back then and you can
think about the city of Duran or Die lon
here and see the ways that Japanese
poetry was being published in places
that are nowadays called China you could
turn on a map
of you know produced by the Japanese
military in the 1930s of dye ran and you
could zoom in and see how the Japanese
understood their own city and the ways
that the publication of these modernist
journals took place in this urban space
now not every country not every language
every civilization is well documented as
20th century Japan so a lot of people
come to me and I say I don't have a
hundred thousand rows in a sequel
database or if I do it's going to take
me a long time to put it together and so
the question is what do you do for
network analysis if you don't have
enough raw data and I think the answer
is just to make up the data yourself and
in a very serious way so what we have is
we have a project that's just under way
here about trying to make sense of
post-world war two European composition
that is a musical works and this project
bait is very simple it's drawn on data
from a Google spreadsheet which is
entered by a team of faculty members and
graduate students it's combined in real
time into a faceted browse and search
mechanism through simile and then
there's a further thing which is kind of
interesting play around with which is
that so here we have MIT simile faceted
browser in saga so she only ligety or
show me only things which are Kestrel in
nature I could go in so these are all
changing here on the left right and I
could look at all so what this team of
researchers called the topos the sort of
qualitative feeling they get when they
listen to a piece and want to make a
value judgment on it so i can say show
me everything that evokes the topos of
Mahler and then the twist we put in is
that we can then visualize that those
connected nodes through the d3.js
visualization here so I can say these
are all the nodes connected to mahler
and these are all these pieces and let's
see you know where ekphrasis comes in
it's connected to these different pieces
right I can release a node back into the
gravitational pool and I can look at it
as a list too and this is what you get
fastest in the right network diagram on
the left and just before I go to that
life slide I think that what's
interesting about this musical
composition example is that it's less
empirical and it's more interpretive
right you're relying on people who
listen to music and to make value
judgments about
there's no shame in that that's what we
should be doing in the humanities right
and as long as we understand these types
of tools as playful explorations as
spaces to play around with this in front
of a class or perhaps in an informal
paper as a place that you can get a
value out of all the data entry you've
done as a way of turning a passive
archive into an active space for
research and exploration I think that
this type of thing is just as offensive
as the highly empirical publication
events of Japanese modernist poetry so
network analysis of course a discipline
and you know it essentially comes in to
a certain degree through social science
right and that's the way I think
humanists have understood network
analysis through the social sciences but
it has its own mathematical basis in
terms of who has been helpful for me in
understanding network analysis as a kind
of d.h practice there are a lot of folks
but a graduate student in catia burners
labs got weingart at iu and then of
course Elijah Meeks at the Stanford
University Library have been
extraordinarily helpful and wonderful
blog posts on this type of discipline
there wasn't any H advanced Institute on
network analysis a couple years ago held
at UCLA which a lot of people went to
let's keep on going down this road of
self-organizing data though and let's
think about we mentioned before that we
could use explicit things like two
pieces sound like Mahler we can say both
poems were published in the same journal
but we can also have implicit or latent
signals within the data and latent
approaches to this type of raw data rely
on course statistical patterns to
separate signal from noise and one
example of this type of work would be or
the types of patterns which can emerge
is based on term occurrence the you know
the phrase you shall know a word by the
company it keeps of Firth in 1957 this
turns out to be true mathematically also
we can discover topics or themes or
discourses from observed documents using
a technique called topic modeling now I
know there is at least one or two
projects here at Yale what you're using
topic modeling and I don't know if
people in the room can raise their hand
if they've heard of topic modeling
before this that's wonderful and people
who've done it themselves right the
numbers go down so
it's it's a complicated thing to explain
and most people say don't try to explain
it especially somebody with his limited
mathematical skills as myself I won't
attempt this is way David Bly computer
scientist at Princeton explains it in
his one of the seminal articles from
2001 on this but the notion to keep in
mind is it's a way of trying to identify
hidden structure or themes within
unlabeled text and it does that by the
counting the co-occurrences of words and
rather than the example the David Bly
uses here which is about genomics I
thought it might make sense to think a
little bit about Carl Sandburg and the
ways that we might topic model Carl
Sandburg so there are three assumptions
behind topic modeling one is that
documents contain topics and that's a
very sort of computer science way to
phrase it I think most humanists would
say that books are about something or
poems are about something right the
second assumption of computer science of
topic modeling is that topics prefer
certain words and the way we would
understand that and literature domain
would be to say that you know themes are
expressed in language right and that the
weirdest part about topic modeling this
is a final third assumption which holds
that poems are novels or any type of
documents might have been created by
choosing words from topix randomly and
this is this generative story is
imaginary we know that people didn't
write this way but it's an important
mathematical trick for something that's
going to come later on so here we have
at the bottom we have Chicago poems
Cornhuskers and smoke and steel and we
know that these those are things which
were actually printed by Sandberg right
and then we have the kind of hidden
structure or the themes of Industry
masculinity the city of Chicago right
and we're trying to discover the
connection between them so again here's
Carl and he's saying i think i'm going
to write a poem today and i'm going to
write a poem about poem has to be about
three things actually be about industry
and masculinity in Chicago so I've got
three buckets in front of me on my desk
and I pick words out one by one
completely randomly and see what comes
out we don't think actually this is how
we wrote poetry but it turns out to be
an interesting game to play with
yourself for the following reason
there's a kind of amazing magic trick in
topic modeling which is statistical
technique that allows us to infer the
hidden structure in further
themes of industry of masculinity of
Chicago all these things by reversing
the generative process so instead of
saying that um essentially what we can
do is we can say what are these poems
about this is easier to show than to
tell and so there's really important
work that's happened in top of modeling
the last couple years one of the most
striking things for me has been to
follow the work of Cameron Blevins a
graduate student in history at Stanford
University who topic model Martha
Ballard's diary so it's a midwife from
Maine and she kept a diary for decades
it was like she was tweeting every day
except she was writing the tweets down
on paper and this was rediscovering the
1970s as part of sort of a feminist
history project and you know the book
was published in Martha Ballard 30 40
years ago what Blevins did was he went
back and he scraped like an online
archive right of all Martha Ballard's
diary and then he topic model it he
tried to use an algorithm to discover
the hidden structure underneath the
unlabeled text and you should go visit
Maura Cameron's blog and read more about
it but this is one example of a theme or
a discourse or a topic that Cameron
discovered or the algorithm discovered
for him which was the topic of gardening
and you can see all the words that are
participate in this discourse of
gardening it's beans corn planted
cucumbers potatoes I mean any person
reading that would know what this topic
is about the algorithm doesn't know what
it's about it just knows that these
words co-occur in order to validate this
approach what Cameron did is he said
give me all these decades worth of these
Diaries and lay january to december over
and over and over each other one by one
and tell me how often this topic is
present is saturated in the individual
diary entries when he did that you get
the curve you're shown here which is
that martha ballard was talking more
about gardening during the point in time
when it was started to become possible
to plant in maine there's also another
great project from the university of
richmond by rob nelson and a team there
about topic modeling a confederate
newspaper called the richmond dispatch
and you can all visit google for mining
the dispatch you'll find this website
which is a fantastic application of
finding hidden structure and unlabeled
data in a confederate newspaper of
making 62 1865 he's got an amazing
examples of here that have to do with
the relationship between fugitive slave
ads and for hire dads and he didn't have
graduate students label these articles
he asked the data to organize itself
based on the frequency of terms that
co-occur so topic modeling as a digital
humanities method is something that's
gained a lot of ground the last couple
years despite the kind of sort of
obscurity of the underlying algorithm
there's this upcoming special issue of
poetics focused on topic modeling the
people that I've learned a lot from have
been reading the work of Ben Schmidt a
postdoc at Harvard cultural observatory
and Ted under word a professor of
English at UIUC just a couple months ago
there was a topic modeling workshop at
myth sponsored by the neh and one of the
things we can do is we can take a corpus
of poetry so let's just take all the
poems published in a given magazine
between 1916 and 1940 and we can ask the
algorithm to go through each of these
poems yeah we're not asking a graduate
student to do this we're asking a robot
to read all of these poems and count how
often words occur in proximity to each
other and it turns out if you do that
then we can see the results here you get
a bunch of interesting topics or in the
words of Ted underwear discourses these
are sort of themes we have the theme of
music and these are poems which are
highly saturated with the theme of music
we have a theme of terrain of the urban
city right and you can see that what's
neat about this particular approach is
that we aren't categorizing these poems
into mutually exclusive categories we're
allowing the poems to participate in
different discourses this particular one
participates in the discourse of both
urban and music right if you scroll down
and you can find some other others are
interesting ones the intangible symphony
here which participates in the discourse
of what we feeling with labeled auditory
and we've labeled it auditory because we
have words music sound voice laughing
right but it also participates in the
discourse of emotion which we thought
was kind of interesting you can read all
these poems by just clicking on a link
and it goes to JSTOR and you can read
the original if there's an ambiguity
that you're trying to figure out but the
poems also are part of this kind of
interconnected network
of hidden structure which has been
discovered by the algorithm here you
have for example symphony of a Mexican
garden which is connected with both
auditory and music which sort of makes
sense if you think about it then if you
drill down on the auditory category you
can find other ones that participate in
discourses of emotion as well as
auditory the twist here comes that as
interesting as it is to be able to
categorize poetry if you were confronted
with an archive it was too big to read
through or if you were interested in the
conversation between your own knowledge
of an archive and an algorithms
understanding of an archive as
interesting as that is what we want to
go further and we want to think about
ways that we can leverage humanities
folks domain expertise but computer
scientists would call domain expertise
your graduate education the books you've
written your dissertation all the work
that you've put into particular author
ships or moments or periods and we want
to figure out if there's a way to keep
that information relevant in a time when
it seems like only algorithms are making
are capable and making sense of the
great unread the archive writ large and
the way to think about this I think is
to use Franco Moretti's term the great
on red is this huge circle on the right
I've just said maybe 1852 1923 you can
cut you can set the limits to whatever
you want them to be and each of us bears
within us knowledge about a specific sub
domain within the grade on red right all
of O'Neal's family dramas about
tuberculosis right were printed and went
on a shelf and were collected and
preserved all of modernist poetry has
been printed right there are novels
about the countryside Irish novel stage
realism plays all of these are subsets
of the great set which is the great on
red and so we know this is our
discipline or expertise this is what we
know so we know there's an inherent
passive relationship here right I mean
with the exception of people who are
studying unpublished works and
manuscripts which is also important but
we know for printed material in google
books there's a passive relationship
between the books that have been
preserved and scanned and the smaller
subset of books that we know really well
and the question really is can we turn
this relationship into an active one can
we use what we know about a particular
field to find interesting things to read
more closely in an enormous sea of books
that have been
20 million at this point and so one
approach that we took on the Google
Books project was just something we term
sub corpus topic modeling and what that
is is to try to apply the algorithm to
sub corpora that are well understood so
this could be again you know everything
that Eugene O'Neill ever wrote or you
know it's in after the inferno period
you know all these things could be
collections that you understand well and
that you've written honor that you know
something about you can take we've done
the works of Darwin and translation
we've done it since stage realism we've
done Danish folklore use your domain
expertise to really look at the models
that are produced by this algorithm to
understand the hidden structure that's
exposed and to make adjustments to say
this is too coarse so this is too fine
and then you can apply what we call
these curated topic models these topic
models which emerge not from a great
mass of unread 19th century poets or
authors but rather from those authors
that you feel you know really well apply
them to everything from internet archive
or apply them to everything from hottie
trust and expose passages and books that
you aren't reading that score highly for
the same topics the same hidden
structure which you find interesting in
your own research we did this as an
example on a gentleman called a volton
Christensen who was a Danish gentleman
he was probably the largest and most
prolific collector of folklore in Europe
he's unknown because he's from Denmark
so we basically were able to take about
was true would take about 14,000 folk
tales from the Jutland Peninsula these
are tales about you know vampires and
werewolves and priests and women and
cows and all the things you'd expect in
rural Europe and 19th century and what
we can do is we can build topic models
from this folklore that we understand
pretty well a lot of work has been done
on this guy and this is just a topic
that is about hearing voices it's about
a bunch of terms at both engrams and
also unitary terms that seem to cohere
and that seemed to co-occur and that
we've labeled hearing voices and these
are all the chunks on the right hand
side here of books from the 19th century
print explosion in Scandinavia which
seemed to score pretty highly for the
topic or for the hidden structure for
the discourse of hearing voices and
here's a particular passage from
book by hillock pontoppidan and we can
analyze these books and analyze these
paragraphs and analyze these things and
figure out is there anything when you do
a close reading on and so for example we
had a whole bunch of folklore that was
co hearing as kind of death in
churchyards unsurprising there's a lot
of folk tales about things that happen
in churchyards people who died in
churchyards the priest who's bearing
everybody and we use as we gently let
the algorithm find all the terms in the
folklore rather than searching for the
word churchyard or searching for the
word priest because we can't we can't
really say that we know what the corpus
is going to be like we want to find a
kind of organic way to let the data
organized itself and unsurprisingly once
we had topic modeled the sub corpus want
to be a topic model the thing we knew
well our disciplinary expertise sort of
obscure folklorist who not many people
have heard of then we sent that topic
model out into the great unread then we
sent it out into thousands and thousands
of Danish books printed in the 19th
century and we said go find as passages
or paragraphs that seem to be highly
saturated with the death in churchyards
topic so this is a passive from Hammond
bangs hallucis Lecter article on excuse
me book about this the starving dog
lying on his master's grave right now we
could have probably found this paragraph
if we had but we couldn't have found it
if we were searching for churchyard
right church are doesn't appear there
cemetery doesn't appear there right and
we wouldn't have found it by find
looking for the word dead right what
we're trying to do is define these
co-occurrence of words that seem to
expose a hidden structure in our sub
corpus and then use that as kind of
velcro or like a fishing hook to attract
other articles so just to review we can
let data unlabeled data without tei
without XML without any kind of human
attention to it just raw dirty OCR with
lots of problems we can let that data
organized itself through computational
methods like topic modeling we can then
curate and evaluate those that sort of
hidden structure that emerges from the
algorithm based on the work we've
already done in graduate school or the
works of the books we've written into
the classes we've talked and then
awkward we can wait till that projector
comes back and we can use that as a way
of finding the aspects of the archive
which are otherwise opaque to us which
completely non transparent in which
don't offer any kind of way in except
for the algorithmic and a problem I
think what's interesting about these
types of approaches is they represent
the complement the sort of complementary
use of algorithmic analysis of
humanistic data rather than saying we're
going to throw away all our hard run
close reading rather than saying we're
going to let robots take over our jobs
we're going to find ways to let the
macroscope complement the microscope
we're going to find ways to let our
hard-won humanistic or historic
historical expertise exist and actually
become more valuable in a world where
the digital has provided us with both
great challenges of scale as well as
great opportunities of new methodologies
thanks very much
okay okay thank you very much I guess I
have a pearl image of starting out at
question and it's a question that I have
that arises from something called the
critical digital humanities so if what
we're doing is telling the robot to read
according to what we already know from
things we've closed right as human
beings why is the computer going to tell
us new things why isn't it just going
where we told it to go in the first
place that's a great question I think
what's something we struggled with a lot
when we were putting this research
project together one thing you might
think would be let's just take all 20
million books from google books and
let's try to figure out how they
organize themselves and the weight one
thing we were afraid of in that scenario
would was that we needed a kind of
Archimedean point we needed a place
outside the grade on red a place that
was somehow anchored in some kind of
humanistic tradition that we knew
whether it was French literature of the
revolution or whether was the
Enlightenment in Germany we needed
something that we fought a sort of a
solid ground on which we could stand
you're right that by making our sub
corpus selection by saying these realist
dramatists right O'Neill abson Shaw you
know but not that but not that realist
dramatist that we're making a choice and
we're probably missing people but one of
the experiments we did for this article
was to topic model all of the discourse
in what in the 19th century Scandinavia
was called the modern breakthrough abson
and strindberg and specifically choose
only male authors and so this was of the
Ipsen and Stromberg and others and then
see what emerged as being somatically
similar algorithmically and what emerged
from be as being somatically similar was
unsurprisingly a whole bunch of women
who were writing on the same themes and
this was kind of a ringer because this
work had already been down the 1970s
people had laborious Lee read the
archive and discovered
entre los Lafleur and others who were
writing of the same themes of sexuality
and family and women's rights and
economic rights as Ipsen and Strindberg
but we wanted this as kind of a test of
our own approach and so what we could
easily do then is combine both male and
female writers for a more diverse take
on the modern breakthrough and as a kind
of sub corpus that would work I've seen
some really amazing work format jockers
recently on taking precisely this gender
division and trying to figure out in his
text mining work if you do have
particular genres which include both men
and women split the men and women apart
and figure out within each genre know
what words are more common what phrases
are more common right so I think it's
dancing around this what we know and
what we don't know it's standing on the
Archimedean point but then being willing
to kind of problem at eyes the
Archimedean point with new data and
that's of course the essence of Bayesian
inference right that's the way that most
statistics is done to assume a prior and
then with new data comes in you just
refresh your assumptions change your
assumptions and let the new the new
insights emerge okay thank you questions
generally yes please just say very
briefly who you are Michael printy at
Wesleyan I actually want to go home is
our topic modeling now so is that
something I can do at home or is this
something that requires a lot of setup
right we heard earlier about software or
particular programs yeah or do I just
need you know a couple of tools in
Google there are some great I think the
situation is much better today than it
was two years ago and it will be better
two years ago of two years in the future
there are some tools that attempt to
wrap the underlying algorithms in kind
of easy to use code there was a hands-on
workshop given at the dhw I the digital
humanities winner Institute by Matt
jockers a couple months ago at Maryland
myth I think he's preparing a book on
text binding with our which is a
statistical package there is some
software from university of illinois the
caesar project fun
by melon but I think the short answer to
you is it's still a little tricky you
have to be comfortable with a command
line and a lot of what the software i
built over the last two years was just
to visualize the results because what we
found was that you could have the
world's most sophisticated algorithm but
if it was spitting out tables of numbers
to standard out on a unix prompt the
penetration of that insight into the
typical English professors head was low
and so a key part of this is going to be
I think actually this follows up with
some of the things that David was
talking about on reusable web-based
tools that aren't completely customized
for everybody but that have some degree
of sophistication and rigor behind them
push down away from the quote unquote
elite and to the level where we all can
create a graph or look at a map or do
these types of things
do this or analogous things with other
media besides text visual auditory or
cross me it's a great question and I
think some so I'm a literature person
not a mathematician but I think one of
the things that makes this world of
algorithmic analysis so interesting is
that the underlying map is truly
universal and people are using topic
modeling to discover reoccurring
patterns of notes and music as long as
you have computationally readable scores
like the kind that we saw from Todd
today you'd be able to do that people
have run topic modeling on on ships logs
Ben Schmidt ran it on ships logs of
whaling voyages to discover sort of
voyages that cohered in time and space
so the neat thing about this is it
really is applicable to almost any type
of human produce culture the caveat
would be that it's I think in my
impression easiest to do on text so far
Andrew from Yale I'm curious about
choosing poetry as a four topic modeling
because poetry depends so much I
metaphor and simile and things like that
that um I'm wondering if sometimes a
topic modeling can it identified topics
but completely missed the point of the
poem right like I'm looking at
Shakespeare's 18th sonnet shall I
compare thee to a summers day write a
topic mightily modeling will pull up
summer weather sun death life but
nowhere in here is except for the phrase
that weren't more lovely there's nothing
about what this topic modeling we pick
get all of that but completely missed
the point of the poem right and i'm now
curious how you would address that in
this so i think that you'd hope that the
algorithm would miss the point otherwise
we'd be obsolete right if the algorithm
could actually discern the point i think
one of the things that an algorithm like
toggle model we might be useful would be
discovering metaphors of seasons in this
poetry right because in some of the work
I've done with this you do see winter
spring summer co here and you see
seasons into all these things on the
exact degree of cohesion of course
depends on the number of topics you
choose there's an interesting
dissertation which was just a
ended at university of maryland by lisa
rody which particular I think believe
tries to discover whether a crisis can
be can be seen by the top of modeling
algorithm and I haven't read her
dissertation so I don't know if the
answer is yes or no but you're right
that this would be a bad choice maybe
for Shakespeare somebody who is so
well-read and so well understood right
even if the sonnets are voluminous this
is like the you know him and Chaucer you
know these are like the big people in
English Lit what's more interesting is
maybe all the Forgotten poets if not the
of the Elizabethan period then certainly
the print explosion of the 19th century
and the 20th century where a lot of
poetry isn't very good and you don't
really want to waste a lot of time
reading it but if you were able to do in
the space of five or ten minutes a parse
of tens of thousands of poems and it
could roughly show you what discourses
this poem poetry participated in might
be worth your time
another another thing that sort of
occurs to me is that it might be
interesting to model how the world press
covers particular disasters say for
instance how the official press and the
bloggers in China cover a train accident
or how you know in order to see the
questions of contemporary questions of
censorship that you know challenge to
that so is there is there work that's
done non on poetry or that kind of but
that kind of it's a great question I
think one of the things that strikes
that jumps out at me from that question
is the work done on the Richmond
dispatchers of course 1860s but what's
interesting about that is that the team
at University of Richmond has really
uncovered all of these discourses that
were present in the Confederate
newspaper on these discourses are what
the computer scientists were taught
called topics have been labeled by Rob
Nelson and his team of historians and
then the most fascinating things you've
ever read because if you're not if
you're not eous southern historian which
I'm not um there's like all these really
interesting themes that emerge of like
the anti northern diatribe the poetry
and patriotism topic all of these ways
that the southerners and many
southerners have many different
viewpoints wrote about themselves and
about their cause and the great thing
about that particular project is it's a
diachronic view so it shows you after
this particular battle how did this
particular theme go up in the newspaper
I think the interface that Robin Nelson
and his team wrote would be a good
starting point for doing that with more
contemporary sources
thanks Lewis from the Yale digital
collection center so I'm not sure I
could express this question but let me
try so it's complicated enough an
algorithm that it's hard to explain and
so I wonder when you're looking at the
results and making assertions how
confident we can continue to be that the
algorithm actually supports the
assertion right when the algorithm is
more and more opaque and I think over
time they probably will get more and
more sophisticated in that way I think
opaque so just to extend on that a
simple thing I've always had a voice to
text analysis for searching through
video is is really strong because even
if you only got fifty percent of the
words right that's fifty percent more
than you ever had you know you never had
fifty percent of access but then the
question is what assertions could you
make about that when you only have fifty
percent so you did all the topic
modeling you are able to to identify
these topics but you probably aren't
clear on what you didn't identify yeah
it's interesting I think that this some
we're still getting used to the notion
of this kind of I'm not going to call it
a black box algorithm because it is well
documented and you know Ted Underwood a
professor at UIUC wrote an
implementation of the algorithm himself
just to understand it there are few of
us including me who could do that but he
did it I think that we are still as a
field of historians and humanists
getting comfortable with this notion of
what appears to us to be a black box
algorithm and I think you're right to
highlight the risks of claims that
emerged from methodologies which are not
well understood and require at least by
people in many people in our field and
we require an increase efficient of math
and bayesian inference and those types
of things one way get around those
problems is to say whenever we present
the results of any kind of analysis have
the text on the right hand side that you
can click on and see what you're
actually seeing so that was a real
priority to me when I wrote that
web-based thing was to
I want to see the poem and I want to see
not only the text but I want to see the
JSTOR page image so that I can read it
through and I can make my own decision
and this was part what I talked about
before about spitting the results of
analysis out to unix command line versus
integrating it into a web-based system
where you can see the text that you're
trying to analyze whether that's a poem
or a paragraph so I think one key to
making people comfortable these types of
things is to always present what's being
analyzed alongside it so you can make
these types of decisions and the other
one is to look at graphs such as Cameron
Blevins produced of the year-over-year
gardening topic and it just strikes me
that um any errors that are there and
there are many right because Martha
Balor didn't use standardized English
spelling right any errors should be we
assume pretty reasonably distributed
right the hypothesis would have to be
that in the winter she used different
words to talk about planting our
gardening right i mean we assume that
there's going to be you know some sort
of a consistent way that she spelled
words even if she spelled in the wrong
way and I think those types of graphs
that have been produced by people like
Nelson and Blevins are really important
because they're a way of checking what
an algorithm is telling us against our
own sort of knowledge of ground truth
like you can't plant in Maine in January
it's going to be a lot of hard work
crayons going to be frozen right so it's
not surprising that people who are
keeping a dire their daily lives start
talking about that in April but I agree
you know David why came to the neh the
trip was there to David Bowie was there
and talked about you know how much how
much is this a black box algorithm do
humanists need to understand it and
unless I'm misremembering he said you
don't need to understand it just you
know this is this works for many many
different fields um it's it's not
something which is going to view an
absolute answer but it's a good first
pass at the data and I think especially
when you consider the alternatives which
are literally reading 20 million books
we may have to have a slightly different
standard for the kind of first pass
guide posting that takes us into the
parts of the archive week actually have
time to read thank you i'm anders winner
of history
I was very happy to see some umlauts on
this crease right I think you already
answered my question when you answered
Lewis but I was wondering you need you
need the corpus to work with the corpus
of texts and you take them for google
books how much of a problem is the OCR
that goes into it which I often noticed
has a particular problem with umlauts
rings yes and are those being being
being solved I often wondered does
google books go over it and and was the
are it again when they have more
sophisticated technology well that's a
great question speaking of black boxes
that is a big one and the I think the
transparency you would hope to see there
would probably come more from hottie
trust which is doing a lot of their own
OCR work on page images from internet
archive even brewster kahle
organizations and this code is very open
about what it does I think you're right
that there are catastrophic problems
with the recognition of a lot of forms
of early even Western European texts
Laura Mandel formerly of miami ohio now
at texas is working on a whole 18th
century OCR project funded by melon for
precisely this problem french and
english but the fonts are different
enough that it's a problem the worst
thing i've ever seen is you know when
frock tour is not recognized as such
then it's truly gobbledygook Joan
Shapiro a book indexer and curious to
know what you think about how this could
be applied down the road into doing
indexes which is the kind of thing I do
now but mostly manually write using
software to help alphabetize and check
my cross references but there's still no
way to to make these cognitive
connections and except to have a person
to a book index and is perhaps a little
bit of a challenge to people in my area
right I wonder if it's going to come
down to individual books it's a great
question i think that um it would be a
you know the one thing you don't want to
give up is the hard-earned you know
decades and centuries long worth of
experience of people working in research
libraries at doing things carefully
especially on treasured collections such
as the Native American collections we
heard about today I would never
recommend any kind of first pass
algorithmic thing on collections where
there were cultural sensitivities or
where there were even if there's a lot
of material if it's worth it to go
through it in my case you're dealing
with like pulp fiction from the 1880s
and it just didn't really seem worth it
to read each one of these bad books you
know but you're right that we might be
able to do first pass even for internal
purposes right putting massive amounts
of text through this type of many
different algorithms not just top of
modeling to guide people with really
specific and skills and experience to be
able to get more of their work done more
quickly even if the final quality
control requires a human touch so my
question is really I think a
clarification but it touches on on some
of the points that have been raised our
radio and by doing a photo am in the
music department so you explain really
well how you can use a well-known sub
corpora to train the model and then you
kind of let that model loose on the
great unread but this are our well
understood sub sub karpoora is already
is this a biased understanding of it so
I'm having trouble making the kind of
understanding how applying that more and
basically that train model on biased
understanding into a great unread how
that's going to yield new perspective on
that great unread so that's kind of the
first part and and then the this the
second part of it is we keep talking
about one person reading 20 million
books and it just I started thinking
about what about 20 million people
reading one book and then talking to
each other in some way so the model is
one person it's one set of eyes is there
any way that we could kind of unleash
many set of eyes which would kind of
avoid maybe some of that bias that is
brought by that well you know well
understood once of course our own sub
corporate and off side makes any sense
no that's a great point I think your
second point really evokes
some of the spirit of what Ray has been
doing up at University of Victoria with
the social addition project which he's
presented on a couple times that I've
heard and I think it's you know really
such a laudable and fascinating attempt
to even if you know there's a spectrum
of many readers right from seven
researchers split across the grow globe
but each at an elite institution all the
way down to some of the experiments by
the library of congress with Flickr and
tagging and focus on amis and things
like that university of michigan has an
interesting content management system
which allows anybody with either
University of Michigan alumni account or
a community account to go in and
annotate not just text but images from
their collections so if you see a
balloon you know in late 19th century
balloon photograph over Detroit and
you're able to label certain areas of
the city of Detroit you can do this and
you know obviously probably they
evaluate those and make sure they aren't
spam but it is really a great sense of
on some of the most difficult things to
do we've heard today about how to do
image annotation and it requires a lot
of infrastructure they're doing it and
they're not doing it on books they're
doing out on images on the first part of
your question is also a great challenge
because it's this tension of if you want
this Euclidean is this kind of
Archimedean point outside the great
unread right but that is that it has
that's the result of a canonization
process right this is what Moretti's
talking about 0.5% right so you have to
take the good with the bad the good news
is we know absent some library that
burned down we don't know about that you
know tan christensen published 47
volumes of danish folklore completely
eclipsing anybody else who published
folklore in that period so if anybody
read folklore in the late 19th early
20th century they were reading 10
Christensen and so we're pretty sure
that that is and we can all think of the
people within our own domains who have
that role right you know xolo and shaw
and all these people in there in the in
the realist movement so i think it's an
interesting problem of i would say to
you just we can use this to expand the
Canon across things like gender across
class across geography even if we start
with a biased sample we can add more
data and revisit our assumptions based
on new observations okay
we are so lucky as to be able to
continue this conversation with Peter in
a few weeks so thank you very much